A fundamental part of
understanding restful APIs
is understanding the components that
make up the client-server flow of HTTP.
HTTP can be described as pull protocol.
Communication is always
initiated by the client
sending an HTTP request to the server.
In turn, the server responds
with a response message.
These messages are just bodies of text
that the machines can later interpret
into actions, images, and
even multimedia content.
Let's briefly discuss some of the major
components of HTTP requests and
responses, starting with requests.
Every HTTP message consists of a message
header, and an optional message body.
These two entities are separated by
a space, like in the diagram here.
In an HTTP request, the first line of
the header is called the request line.
The request line contains the HTTP verb,
the URI, or
Uniform Resource Identifier,
and the HTTP version number.
Take a look at these
examples of request lines.
We see the verb here, the resource we
want to access via the URI here, and
the version of HTTP we
are using at the end.
After the request line we have
the optional request headers.
These are perimeters that can be
used to describe specific properties
about a request.
Request headers appear
in name value pairs.
Multiple values can be
separated by commas, like so.
A blank line separates the header and
body of an HTTP request.
In the body, we can add any other
information about the request that we
want to send along to the server.
An example of a complete HTTP
request message is shown here.